your faithful catholic meaning you
believe everything the church teaches
yes everything yes everything yes so you
are uh
uh you see that uh the use of
contraception is against uh natural
moral law yes as destructive a doorway
to abortion i've done all that and
everything else you see the whole
everything going on with roe for example
right now and all the left you know
becoming completely uncourt losing their
minds the question you know they're
saying they're coming after your gay
marriage next they're coming after your
birth control after that and everything
else well you know what yeah
absolutely
yes so we need to um make a plain
statement of fact which is the reason
why the west is great is because western
civilizations underpinning is
christianity you
cannot have a successful society outside
of the christian
moral order and things like abortion and
things like gay marriage are outside of
the christian moral order and they lead
to chaos and destruction and a culture
of death which is why we're seeing that
today we have abandoned the christian
moral order as a nation and we are
reaping that destruction how do you
answer the local
press person who might be your age just
sees you as some
loony who then she wants to take away
your birth control well in the state of
michigan sure so i guess we have to ask
ourselves would that ever come to a vote
um in the michigan state legislature and
if it should i would have to side with
it should not be legal i think that
people believe that birth control is pro
it's
better like you said because oh then you
won't get pregnant and you won't need to
have an abortion but i think that it
gives people the false sense of security
that they can have consequence free sex
and that's not true and it's not correct
sex ought to be between one man and one
woman in the confines of marriage and
open to life and open to life absolutely
i'm not going to void the truth we're
going to tell the truth here and i'm
going to tell you exactly who these
[ __ ] are and we're going to
continue to tell you who they are i got
a video mj sent it to me of some
religious zealot some handmaid's tale
whack-a-doo up in michigan is running
for state legislator and she gave an
interview to some other whack-a-dude
traitor christian tv network or some
[ __ ] his christianity stuff is getting a
little out of hand in this country
getting way the [ __ ] out of hand look i
don't give a [ __ ] where you're from what
religion what church you went to whether
you went to church whether you grew up
in church or what church you go to now
and all that nonsense whatever whatever
the [ __ ] you want to do it's your right
to [ __ ] believe whatever wacky [ __ ]
you want to believe fine it's my right
to not believe any of that [ __ ] those
are your thoughts those are your beliefs
that's your [ __ ] religion fine
perfect whatever you want to do but the
american christian church in general
especially evangelicals are getting more
and more like the american taliban
whether one i mean
this video that i'm gonna show you today
they're talking about banning all
contraception in oklahoma we see a bill
where the moment that the sperm hits the
egg it's an abortion you don't think
they're gonna check women for iuds you
don't think they're gonna do government
checks what's next where are they gonna
go to next don't [ __ ] tell me that
i'm losing my goddamn mind i'm telling
you in this video i'm gonna show you
they're like yeah you goddamn right
we're coming after gay marriage you
goddamn right we're coming after
contraception you [ __ ] a right that's
our next goal that's our next mission
they're not gonna stop fascist don't
stop unless we stop them this [ __ ]
whack-a-doo looney tune crazy-ass
squirrel turd up in michigan i don't
know what the [ __ ] her name is it
doesn't even matter what her name is
because there's a there's a hundred more
right behind her that are willing to try
to take over the government she acts
like our entire country is built on a a
christian moral code no it's called the
constitution you [ __ ] idiot that's
why they [ __ ] hate the constitution
that's why they love trump that's why
they love trumpism that's why they love
maga that's why they love dark maga
because dark magga and trumpism fascism
in a manga hat they love it because it
will tear down our constitution which
grants people that they don't like and
they want to oppress rights how is this
so [ __ ] hard this is not difficult to
understand it will never be difficult to
understand everyone thinks i have some
kind of crystal ball i don't have a
crystal ball i just know who these
people are they're sick whack-a-loons
they're ready to take your rights at all
costs all cost even destroying our
democracy which they don't like because
our democracy grants you the people they
don't like
liberty fornicators spoon benders
muslims jews atheists blacks latinos
brown people all the people they don't
like the constitution is supposed to
afford them rights and they definitely
don't like that [ __ ] [ __ ] they
believe in a white crystal fascist
nation they want a nazi state what don't
you understand about this what don't
people get if you let them have control
and have power they're coming after you
they're coming after your job they're
coming after your church they're coming
after your community they're coming
after your education all of it your way
of life is not what they want i don't
care if you're if you go to church and
you vote republican and you're a
suburbanite i don't give a [ __ ] they're
coming after you all those years that
you voted republican thinking oh i'll
just lower my taxes so i can live in my
mcmansion and have my suvs enjoy my
whiteness they're coming after that too
cause i know you i know you use
contraception i know you [ __ ] like stone
test bunnies you suburbanites out there
who pretend that the american dream is
something that it's not you pretend
you're rich like elon musk and you're
not you pretend like the government's
gonna come for you in taxes and they're
not the government's gonna come for your
guns and they're not they're coming for
your way of life they're coming to make
you bend to their fascist ways that's
what they're gonna do doubt me i don't i
don't give a [ __ ] i mean i'll show you
proof because we're not gonna look away
here on the tony michael's podcast no
[ __ ] way but this wacko loon this
looney tunes q anon evangelical
christian
cristofascism in this country enough is
enough and how we stop it is we use the
[ __ ] ballot it's the same way we stop
them from starving brown people at brown
children at the border because they
don't want them to have baby formula
they're not they're not good enough
they're not white enough to have baby
formula down there at the border so let
them babies starve if you're a clump of
cells you're good you're good if you're
a clump of cells in oklahoma god damn
if that sperm has hit the egg you're a
[ __ ] human being can you imagine the
insanity that we have to acknowledge in
oklahoma because you cross an imaginary
line that somehow sperm eating an egg is
a human being that's what the [ __ ]
they're saying and all you dumb
[ __ ] out there that are
bitching and moaning about taxes and gas
prices you don't get it gas prices and
taxes aren't gonna [ __ ] matter that's
not what's gonna matter to them you're
not you're not even gonna have to
[ __ ] worry about gas prices and taxes
when these fascists take over there's so
much more [ __ ] to worry about
checkpoints mandatory medical exams you
don't think that's next you don't think
some crazy republican [ __ ] isn't
going to put a piece of legislation in a
state that says women have to have
mandatory medical exams to make sure
they're not implanted with contraception
you don't think [ __ ] that's next hell i
said two weeks ago they were gonna ban
condoms some dumb [ __ ] decides
he's gonna ban condoms mark my words the
next two weeks there'll be a [ __ ]
bill somewhere you'll see it on twitter
someone will [ __ ] put an article
where there's some [ __ ] wackaloon
some goddamn crystal fascist some dark
manga [ __ ] out there who holds a
seat in power because taxes and god and
religion and guns and abortion holds a
[ __ ] seat somewhere in a state
congress and a state legislator
introduces a bill to have mandatory
medical exams for women to make sure
they're not hiding their contraception
to think that we're going to have one
state that's for women's rights and
another state that's not [ __ ] that's
not their goal their goal is not to have
a confederacy their goal is to topple
our democracy they want autocracy they
want to control you they want to tell
you what the [ __ ] to do and they will
continue this scourge they will not stop
unless we stop them and the way we stop
them is the ballot i don't give a [ __ ]
if you voted republican your entire life
i don't care if you're a conservative i
don't give a rat's [ __ ] ass if you
consider yourself a pro-lifer now is the
time to be pro-democracy now right
[ __ ] now yesterday a week ago two
weeks ago when they were talking about
banning condoms now is the time to be
pro-democracy anti-autocracy now is the
[ __ ] time there's never a
better time to be against autocracy than
right now because that's what they're
gonna do that's where they're going with
this and they're not going to quit so we
can't quit because if we quit we are
definitely [ __ ] the great news is we
still have a constitution in this
country it still lives it still brees
and it beat back their fascist cheeto
dust kangaroo coup attempt and this next
election is the most important election
and the one after that will be the most
important and the one after that will be
the most important because they're not
just going to go uh well they beat us in
the midterms so so much for fascism
when you see this video of this lady of
this q a nut bag because you know she's
a q a nut bag there's no [ __ ] way
around it no way around it she doesn't
believe the full-on delusion the full-on
manga dark maga trump delusion no
[ __ ] way she didn't believe that [ __ ]
it's almost like she's [ __ ]
hypnotized when you watch this video
saying [ __ ] that people haven't [ __ ]
uttered in front of a camera in decades
but they're back folks they're back and
boy are they are they ready to fight to
kill your democracy your democracy it's
yours i mean only if you are willing to
keep it and i'm not just talking to
[ __ ] the [ __ ] libs and the socialists
out there the bernie bros the people who
wear the biden hats i'm talking to you
conservatives who live in suburbia i'm
talking to you who vote republican
because you want low taxes and you want
to keep your guns you don't think the
[ __ ] fascists are gonna come for your
guns you don't think the fascists are
gonna be the first to come to your
[ __ ] house and take your goddamn guns
away from you so that you can't use them
on them you're out of your [ __ ] mind
they want to ban contraception the one
thing the one [ __ ] thing that
prevents abortions the most if you
really are anti-abortion like that's
your [ __ ] stance if you're really
anti-abortion and that's your stance
[ __ ] contraception should be way up
on the top of the [ __ ] list why
why why does contraception why would
that why would that prevent abortions
huh i wonder why i don't know go down
oklahoma and ask them what a [ __ ]
human being is because they don't even
know what the [ __ ] a human being is in
folks they really don't give a [ __ ]
that's the [ __ ] that's the that's the
rub about the bill that stit's gonna
sign in oklahoma that's gonna be [ __ ]
law immediately as that [ __ ] fascist
puts his ink on the page that [ __ ]
nazi he doesn't give a [ __ ] if the
reality is that a sperm and an egg
kissing isn't a [ __ ] human being he
doesn't care the only thing he gives a
[ __ ] about is telling you what the [ __ ]
to do and what not to do and he's gonna
get government all up in your [ __ ] all
up in it so if you're out there in
superbia and you vote republican and you
think you're conservative because of
taxes and guns and god well they're
gonna take your god they're gonna take
your guns and they're gonna tax the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of you